i like to offer
readers the opportunity to ask you
questions or ask
you know the stars questions and i got a
really good question i think from a
reader that i'd like to ask you
i believe his name is james gunn um
he said uh what makes james gunn so much
better than any other director you've
worked with
uh that's that's an easy question to
answer
uh james is everything and the reason
that he's such a great director is
because he assumes
all roles he creates the story from the
ground up
he supervises the story as a producer he
manages all personalities uh when
they're on set
as a coach he's very
determined in his selection process of
the cast so he's a casting agent
uh he's meticulous on small detail so
he's wardrobe design
he's a ridiculously intricate
storyboarder
so he's a production designer as well i
think his ability
to have his hands in everything he's
like
he's almost like the vince mcmahon of of
a movie
vince is is involved in everything and
wants to be and i mean everything from
like
and this is james as well marketing and
certainly putting himself out there uh
the suicide squad
a james gunn film he's he's putting his
stamp on that which means he believes in
the product and he does that
so fluently because he's invested in
every piece of it he has
confidence in in what he does that's
he's
he's just too many things at once i i
gotta know how much does it cost to get
you to say something like that
is it ten bucks or twenty bucks uh
there's no currency that'll do that
that's literally that's
action like all you got to do is live
that and by the way it's damn near
impossible to live
no no totally i i appreciate i'm i'm
sure james is going to like that uh
what do you think i love learning about
the behind the scenes of the making of a
movie
so what do you think people would be
surprised to learn about the making of
f9
oh man that the fast family exists like
i have such fond memories especially
because the world kind of shut down on
all of us unexpectedly
of just hanging out with the fast family
it really is like the barbecues we we
drink we have food we
talk with each other about things other
than the project we're working on or
what we have
coming up next we talk about genuine
life and
hardships and triumphs and our stories
and uh
it's it's awesome the other stuff is
expected it's a grandiose production
that makes the impossible possible like
everything is awesome
like it's it's a really unique
experience in that regard
but the thing i really value the most is
the camaraderie between the people on
set
i have to ask you what has justin told
you about
a fast 10 or a future installments of
transports
nothing and i like it that way i don't
like to be
involved in a process that i shouldn't
be involved in
uh vin is the heartbeat of the franchise
and justin certainly at the helm of the
next one
they need to do what's best for them and
i've told both of them point blank
i'm grateful i'm so grateful for this
opportunity and if the future of fast
exists without me
that doesn't take away from my enjoyment
or excitement
or gratitude for all that's going on
right now they need to do what's best
for the movie not what's best for me
i have to stop there i'm just going to
say congrats on being part of the movie
fans are going to [ __ ] love it
they're going to extra an excellent fan
question